Donald Trump has received
disastrous news from his own former
lawyer Ty Cobb his name is really Ty
Cobb Ty Cobb believes
Trump will end up convicted and in
prison
for one of Trump's own former lawyers to
say this is really something uh Donald
Trump's former attorney has boldly
predicted that the former president is
going to jail
as the criminal investigation into the
Trove of classified documents found at
Mar-A-Lago continues to heat up Ty Cobb
who worked as a White House attorney for
the Trump Administration from July 2017
to May 2018 said to CNN the evidence
against Trump will lead to a conviction
and prison time reminder this is
separate from Georgia where an
indictment may be coming this is
separate from the pre-existing arrest
and indictment of trump this is its own
this is for the the documents in Florida
quote I wouldn't necessarily expand the
case to try to prove the Espionage Act
piece of it because there's so much
evidence of guilty knowledge on the
Espionage piece that all they really
have to do is show that Trump moved
these documents at various times when
doj was either demanding them or
actually present that he filed falsely
with the justice department had his
lawyers file falsely with the justice
department and affidavit to the effect
that none existed meaning no documents
which was shattered by the documents
they discovered after the search and the
many other misrepresentations yes I do
think he will go to jail on it
uh Business Insider reports a former
White House lawyer believes Trump will
go to jail Ty Cobb said there was quote
so much evidence of guilty knowledge as
investigations continue the doj is
probing whether Trump obstructed Justice
in bringing classified documents to
Mar-A-Lago if other people did what
Trump did they would certainly be
prosecuted now you know sometimes you'll
see legal analysts or non-usually it's
more like non-legal analysts say anybody
who did this would be convicted and
sentenced to prison conviction is of
much different thing right the criminal
standard of guilt Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt
it's very hard to predict conviction but
what we can say with certainty is that
if other people did what Trump did with
regard to the documents they would
certainly be prosecuted and then we
would look at whether they get convicted
and the most important aspect of all of
this is that no one should be above the
law should being the critical word
the last part of this
speculating on the outcome of ongoing
investigations in a sense can be
misleading and it is true that when you
hear a lawyer like Ty Cobb say you go
wow this this is not just a random
lawyer this is not a random left-wing
lawyer this is a lawyer who worked for
Trump and that does carry strength and
so I think we should listen to what Ty
Cobb says at the same time
investigations can be fickle these
things have to run their course we want
impartiality when it comes to the
justice system and so when Ty Cobb makes
these predictions they're worth noting
given his knowledge and associations
with a former president Donald Trump but
also we should approach all of it with
caution let the investigations play out
and be guided by evidence and for the
time being I have every reason to
believe that that is exactly
what the justice department has been
doing
I can't imagine if you are Trump you're
thrilled when your own former lawyer
says I think you're going to prison but
let's wait and see because it's
certainly one of many possible outcomes
here
we've talked on the show about how
internet service providers have been
logging everything their customers do
online and selling that data tech
companies use trackers in websites and
apps to collect your data you can Shield
yourself from all of it by using a VPN
every time you connect to the internet
the VPN I use is private internet access
it's the only VPN that has proven
multiple times in court they do not log
your activity our sponsor private
internet access hides my IP address
prevents big Tech from being able to
paint a picture of who I am and what I
do online and it works for all of your
favorite streaming platforms like
Netflix and Hulu to access shows and
movies normally only available in other
countries it's one of the only vpns that
works for peer-to-peer file sharing and
the best part is you can protect
unlimited devices with just one account
going online without private internet
access is like leaving your phone
unattended in a crowded room anyone can
just take a glance my audience gets 83
percent off that's just 203 a month plus
four extra months for free go to
piavpn.com Pacman the link is down below